[Musique]
à la une la sphère alexeï navalni au
coeur des tensions entre la russie et
l'europe moscou expulsé des diplomates
allemands polonais et suédois accusé
d'avoir participé à une manifestation en
faveur de l'opposant russe une décision
survenue après une rencontre entre les
chefs de la diplomatie russe et
européenne
bruxelles berlin et paris la condamne
fermement illustration l'allemagne a
convoqué l'ambassadeur russe la russie
dans le viseur de joe biden pour le
président américain washington ne va
plus je cite se soumettre face à moscou
en réaction le crabe l'un des noms
secrets truc très agressive mais laisse
une porte ouverte à la coopération
le chef de la maison blanche a dévoilé
hier les grandes lignes de sa politique
étrangère
on retiendra aussi la fin du soutien à
la coalition saoudienne au yémen pas
d'euro confinement en métropole en
revanche à mayotte oui le territoire
français de l'océan indien est
confrontée à une explosion de cas
d'e.coli 19 mis sous cloche total qui
débute ce soir pour une durée de trois
semaines
les écoles seront fermées on se rendra à
mamoudzou dans ce journal pour faire le
point sur la situation
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france on commence avec
les tensions diplomatiques entre la
russie et l'europe sur fond d'affaires
alexeï navalni moscou a expulsé des
diplomates allemands polonais suédois au
motif qu'ils ont participé à une
manifestation de soutien à l'opposant
russe des rassemblements interdits le 23
janvier à saint pétersbourg et dans la
capitale russe aujourd'hui le ministère
allemand des affaires étrangères a
convoqué l'ambassadeur russe à berlin
pour lui signifier son désaccord
condamnation unanime de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel et d'emmanuel
macron on va les écouter s'exprimer
aujourd'hui c'était lors d'un conseil
franco allemand de défense
j'ai dit que nous avions avec la russie
ce qui est je crois un état de fait
une histoire commune et une géographie
commune la russie est en europe et donc
que notre intérêt était d'avoir une
discussion permanente ce que nous
faisons d'ailleurs madame la chancelière
et moi-même séparément et ensemble avec
le président poutine et je pense qu'il
est important de continuer à le faire
j'ai aussi dit que en effet nous avions
une littérature une culture un
imaginaire commun
pour ce qui est des valeurs
démocratiques libéral je crois que je
n'ai jamais perdu la lucidité jusqu'à
considérer que nous les partagions
aujourd'hui et vous ne m'avez jamais
entendu le dire pendant la réunion
nous avons été informés de l'expulsion
de diplomates polonais allemand et d'un
autre pays
après les manifestations qui ont lieu
autour de la ferme avanies ses diplômes
elles ont été expulsé de russie
je crois que c'est une autre facette de
ce que l'on voit se dérouler
actuellement russie concernant le manque
d' état de droit on fait le point sur
les réactions côté russe avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera kaufmann le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
a déclaré ce 5 janvier l'expulsion de
trois employés des ambassades de pologne
de suède et d'allemagne
les trois diplomates ont été déclarés
persona non grata pour avoir participé à
des manifestations illégales en moscou
et saint pétersbourg le 23 janvier
je vous propose d'écouter la déclaration
du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères
le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères a convoqué l'ambassadeur du
royaume de suède
le chargé d'affaires de la pologne et
l'envoyé de l'ambassade d'allemagne
ces diplomates se sont vus remettre une
note de protestation après que la
participation de membres du personnel
diplomatique des consulats généraux du
royaume de suède et de la république de
pologne à saint pétersbourg ainsi que de
l'ambassade d'allemagne à moscou a été
enregistré dans les manifestations
illégales du 23 janvier dernier il a été
souligné que de tels actes de leur part
étaient inacceptables et incompatibles
avec leur statut de diplomate en vertu
de la convention de vienne sur les
relations diplomatiques daté du 18 avril
les diplomates ayant participé aux
manifestations illégales ont été
déclarés persona non grata ils devront
quitter le territoire de la fédération
de russie dans les meilleurs délais la
partie russe espère que par la suite les
missions diplomatiques du royaume de
suède de la république de pologne et
d'allemagne ainsi que leur personnel
respecterons strictement les normes du
droit international
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell qui s'est entretenu dans
la matinée avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov a condamné fermement
l'expulsion de trois diplomates a fait
savoir son porte parole
les autorités russes ont dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises l'ingérence des pays
occidentaux dans les affaires russe
pointant du doigt la présence des
diplomates occidentaux lors de
l'audience d'alexia navale n'est les
appels de gouvernements occidentaux à la
libération de l'opposant aux russes ou
encore l'indication sur le site de
l'ambassade américaine à moscou des
heures et les lieux de mobilisation non
autorisée pour navale né en russie
je vous rappelle il s'agit des
manifestations du 23 janvier des
milliers de manifestants étaient
descendus dans les rues dans de
nombreuses villes du pays ces
rassemblements n'ont pas reçu
l'autorisation des autorités les
manifestants exigeaient la libération de
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni
incarcéré pour non respect des
conditions d'une peine de prison avec
sursis à son retour en russie le 17
janvier
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure le
président français lui reste convaincu
qu'il existe des positions communes
entre l'europe et la russie
écoutez à ce propos l'analyse de pierre
emmanuel thomas née les professeurs en
géopolitique et fondateur d'euro
continent et à une escalade parce que la
russie considère qu'il ya une ingérence
sur son territoire avec la sphère
navalni ou des diplomates européens
soutiennent en fait ces manifestations
alors que la russie considère que c'est
une affaire interne et on va plutôt dans
la mauvaise direction aujourd'hui alors
même que l'europe justement avec
l'installation d'un nouveau président
européen aurait intérêt à montrer
qu'elle a besoin d'une bonne coopération
avec la russie
parce que le projet européen sont la
russie ne fera pas le poids dans le
monde face vis-à-vis de l'émergence de
cette rivalité américano chinoises et
cette affaire nabhani est est un grain
de sable qui a été créée de toutes
pièces par c c et réseaux atlantiste et
il serait bon d'avoir la tête plus
froide et de revenir à une coopération
plus moi moins dépendant de ces de ces
crises qui sont volontairement provoqué
mais pour l'instant nous avons nous
faisons face à une escalade et il était
logique que la situation à gaza grave
parce que la russie ne se laissera rien
dictée surtout sur ses affaires
intérieures
et justement outre la ferme à vannes il
a été question ce matin des relations
russo européennes c'est donc chaud et
froid en ce moment eu lieu à moscou
cette rencontre entre les chefs de la
diplomatie russe et européenne une
première depuis 2017
josep borrell a condamné l'expulsion par
la russie de plusieurs diplomates mais
ce matin aux côtés de sergueï lavrov il
a évoqué une volonté commune de
travailler ensemble malgré les
différends au menu également l'épidémie
de coronavirus l'occasion pour le
diplomate européen de saluer spoutnik v
le vaccin bus c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'humanité at il affirmé écouter ce
qui est propice pour l'humanité entière
hassan aux offres encore abouti à lutter
contre la pandémie
j'étais heureux à lire
et pour s'identifier publiée dans une
revue prestigieuse scientifique lens est
à l'article qui a été consacré à une
autre
efficacité du vaccin russe et j'espère
que maintenant l'agencé européenne des
médicaments sur est en mesure de donner
une sens autorisé l'utilisation de ce
vaccin sur le territoire des pays
faisant partie de l'union ça nous
donnerait une bonne nouvelle parce que
qu'on vous le savez le vaccin ne manque
maintenant et julian a de nouveau à
féliciter les scientifiques russes pour
leur succès est là aussi au coeur du
discours également la nuit dernière de
joe biden sur la politique étrangère
américaine dans le viseur de washington
également pékin ou encore ryad
les précisions de quentin mots clairs
l'amérique est de retour la diplomatie
est de retour au discours pour redorer
le blason des états unis joe biden s'est
exprimée cette nuit sur les futurs
contours de la politique étrangère
américaine
faire table rase de la diplomatie mise
en place par donald trump
le président américain a déclaré s'être
entretenu avec la dîmière poutine
objectif de cet appel téléphonique
prévenir son homologue russe des
changements à venir dans les relations
entre les deux pays
j'ai clairement dit au président poutine
d'une façon très différente de mon
prédécesseur que le temps où les états
unis se soumettait face aux actes
agressifs de la russie comme l'ingérence
dans nos élections
les cyber attaques l'empoisonnement de
ses citoyens est révolu nous
n'hésiterons pas à faire payer le prix
fort à la russie et à défendre les
intérêts vitaux de notre peuple un
discours offensif envers la russie qui a
été aussitôt condamnée par le kremlin
à notre grand regret c'est une
rhétorique très agressive et où
constructive
le ton de l'ultimatum est il acceptable
à nos yeux nous avons déjà dit que nous
ne tiendrons pas compte de telles
déclarations
à savoir une déclaration dont le but est
de nous faire la leçon aux tracteurs
évoqué dans le discours de joe biden la
chine le président américain montre les
dents et durcit le ton face à la
politique internationale de pékin nous
allons nous opposer aux abus économiques
de la chine compterait sa ligne de
conduite agressive pour repousser les
attaques de la chine contre les droits
de l'homme la propriété intellectuelle
et la gouvernance mondiale
mais nous sommes prêts à travailler avec
pékin quand il est dans l'intérêt de
l'amérique de le faire enfin joe biden a
annoncé la fin du soutien américain la
coalition saoudienne engagés dans la
guerre au yémen
une décision saluée par ryad qui affirme
son soutien à une solution politique
cette guerre doit cesser et pour
souligner notre détermination nous
mettons fin à tout soutien américain aux
opérations offensives dans la guerre au
yémen y compris aux ventes d'armes sur
le plan digues ratoire joe biden prend
également une direction drastiquement
opposé à son prédécesseur
les états unis vont accueillir 125 mille
réfugiés par an soit un nombre
d'admissions plus de huit fois supérieur
à celui de la présidence de donald trump
ne veut plus vendre d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite engagés dans la guerre au yémen
une décision qui ne convainc pas
vraiment les habitants de la capitale
yéménite sanaa écoutez corax à la la
récente décision américaine ne cesser de
soutenir l'arabie saoudite ne fera
aucune différence car les entrepôts
saoudiens sont remplis d'armes
américaines et israéliennes
nous étions optimistes à l'idée que
quelque chose de bien se produirait mais
ça ne sert à rien nous pensions pourtant
qu'il prendrait des décisions plus
efficaces qui pourraient mettre fin à
l'hostilité contre le peuple du yémen
nous pensions aussi qu'il allait arrêter
d'armes américaines et saoudiennes qui
tuent des femmes et des enfants après l
annonce de la décision de baden nous ne
voyons rien de bon venir parce que
l'origine de cette guerre a été annoncé
depuis washington la décision d'arrêter
cette guerre n'interviendra que si elle
est également pris à washington
concernant les discussions nous avons
entendu souvent ce genre de promesses et
nous ne voyons pas ce que cela changera
à moins que des mesures concrètes soient
prises et en aura plusieurs pays
refusent que leurs armes soient
utilisées dans la guerre au yémen c'est
le cas de l'allemagne de l'italie
qu'annoncé fin janvier l'arrêt des
exportations d'armes vers l'arabie
saoudite ou les emirats arabes unis
également engagés dans le conflit
yéménite
en revanche la france reste à la traîne
selon benoît murat de sol président de
l'association action c'est qu'ils ont
été été créée public et adam l'écoutent
nous avons l'allemagne même si rail
métal continue à travers l'afrique du
sud notamment où là la sardaigne donc
l'italie continuer d'envoyer des armes
en arabie saoudite
il ya quelques yahia une onde de choc
extrêmement importante c'est à dire que
tous ses états le font parce qu'ils
savent qu'il y à des crimes de guerre
nous venons de sortir un rapport qui est
d'ailleurs disponible sur notre site
internet
azer tirer à ce point org qui dit que ce
sont des crimes contre l'humanité
donc maintenant toutes les capitales du
monde le savent la question c'est juste
une question de complicité
dia dans de nombreux pays la question
des droits de l'homme qui est quand même
centrale
en france elle ne l'est plus ça c'est
extrêmement gras et mais ça va être de
plus en plus difficile notamment à la
grande bretagne pour la grande bretagne
et la france de continuer à suppléer ces
deux pays au moins ces deux pays
si l'hexagone échappent pour l'instant
au confinement ce n'est pas le cas de
mayotte l'île sous cloche dès ce soir et
pour trois semaines
les autorités s'inquiètent de la
progression de plusieurs variants dans
ce territoire d'outre-mer déjà en partie
à confiner envoie cela avec walid
bennani et solène god à mayotte
exception française
lille airs confiné annonce sur le site
internet du ministère d outre mer depuis
le 1er février trois communes bouhenni
pamandzi dzaoudzi labattoir était
confiné du fait de l'observation de taux
d'incidence particulièrement élevé afin
de limiter la forte circulation du virus
il a été décidé d'étendre le confinement
à l'ensemble du territoire mahorais à
compter du vendredi 5 février 18h pour
une durée de trois semaines
mayotte victimes des variantes du coc
vite 19 notamment sud africain et
britanniques
le gouvernement a donc décidé de ne
prendre aucun risque et d'isoler
l'archipel de l'océan indien
il ne s'agit évidemment pas d'empêcher
nos concitoyens qui sont aujourd'hui en
déplacement à l'étranger de revenir chez
eux
il s'agit en revanche d'arrêter tous les
déplacements qui ne répondent pas à une
nécessité absolue
et c'est notamment le cas de tous les
voyages touristiques
nous ne le faisons pas pour nous
protéger cette fois ci d'un risque accru
dans ces territoires car l'épidémie
il circule encore très modérément mais
au contraire pour les protéger d'un
risque de contamination en provenance de
la métropole ou de l'étranger comme le
montre la situation de mayotte selon les
derniers chiffres du ministère de
l'outre-mer le taux d'occupation des
lits en réanimation dépasse les 100%
un service qui accueille désormais des
patients plus jeunes âgés de 45 à 60 ans
depuis une semaine une unité de réserve
sanitaire de 30 médecins infirmiers ou
encore biologiste et mobiliser certains
patients en réanimation ont également
été transférés vers un autre département
et région d'outre-mer
la réunion face à cette situation
préoccupante
les autorités ont tenu à rassurer la
population l'accès à l'eau potable sera
notamment possible ce confinement est
nécessaire pour freiner la circulation
du virus et de ces variants nous serons
aux côtés des mahoraises et mahorais
pour les soutenir dans cette épreuve
des mesures d'urgence économique seront
mises en place ainsi qu'une aide
alimentaire la solidarité nationale sera
au rendez vous et contrairement à la
métropole
les écoles et les établissements
scolaires qui accueille des milliers
d'élèves ferment leurs portes les jeunes
particulièrement touchés par le
coronavirus dans ce dom où l'âge moyen
est de vendre deux ans on en parle tout
de suite avec estelle youssoufa
journaliste indépendante et président du
collectif des citoyens de mayotte
bonsoir à vous remercier d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
explosion de cas à mayotte comment
l'expliquer écoutez pour nous les choses
sont claires les et les autorités ont
attendu trop longtemps on a appris que
dominique voynet la directrice de la rs
a lancé une alerte le 5 janvier à paris
et on voit que la décision de
confinement n'a n'est intervenue que un
mois plus tard on a perdu un mois de
confinement qui aurait permis de
ralentir la propagation du virus le
préfet la directrice de la rs 1 ont
répété qu'ils ne voulaient pas fermer le
et proclamé le confinement pour protéger
l'économie clandestine protéger les
trafics et donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui a constaté ce mur épidémique
que les médecins décrivent au chm qui
est complètement saturé des malades qui
sont envoyées à la réunion des
opérations et des traitements courants
qui sont annulés moi je rappelle quand
même et c'est important de le comprendre
mayotte c'est un désert médical
on ne peut pas comprendre que les
autorités des coûts
la proximité avec l'afrique du sud alors
que les autorités sud africaines ont
lancé l' alerte le 18 décembre les
kwassa qui sont remplis de comoriens qui
entrent illégalement à mayotte dont
certains sont contaminés continuent à
arriver quotidiennement sur les plages à
mayotte
donc en fait toute la stratégie
sanitaire qui a été mise en place au
niveau national n'existe pas
effectivement à mayotte et on en paye
aujourd'hui le prix je rappelle que
l'année dernière il ya eu 40 % de
surmortalité à mayotte en craint le pire
parce que là ce qu'on vit est bien pire
que ce qui s'est passé l'an dernier au
début pour la première vague mayotte
avait été relativement et je pèse mes
mots il y en avait été relativement
épargnée avec quand même 40 % de
mortalité est là cette fois on a une
situation qui est beaucoup plus alarmant
parce que ce sont des patients qui sont
plus jeunes il y aurait eu le décès de
quelqu'un qui avait à peine 25 ans avec
des personnes qui ont entre 40 et 65 ans
qui ont des formes de détresse
respiratoire hyper importante et qui
sont très nombreuses l'hôpital nous dit
qu'il ya environ une dizaine de patients
qui arrivent en détresse on développe la
médecine à domicile le problème c'est
que comme en un désert médical il ya
très peu de médecins de ville pas assez
de soignants et puis nous soignons ils
sont aussi épuisé un commun comme dans
le reste du pays
donc vous parler de l'afrique du sud
tout à l'heure pas très loin de mayotte
sackey la crainte d'avoir circulé le
variant sud africain notamment à mayotte
quels sont vos informations à ce niveau
non en fait
évidemment on parle du variant sud
africain parce que ce sont les autorités
sud africaines qui ont observé les
variations comment dire au niveau de
l'évolution du du virus mais en réalité
le foyer épidémique qui a contaminé
mayotte île et aux comores voisines
et comme nos frontières sont des
passoires qu'on a tous les jours dd quoi
ça qui arrive avec des personnes qui
sont malades ou avec des personnes qui
sont contaminées
qui ne passe pas évidemment de tests
puisqu'elle rentrer illégalement sur le
territoire et ben en fait toute la
stratégie de mettre la france sous
cloche pour la protéger de l'infection
ou de la propagation du courant navires
us quand vous avez le chef de l'état le
président macro qui annonce qu on ferme
les frontières du territoire national
c'est pas le cas à mayotte
parce qu'il continue jusqu'à ce jour à y
avoir d entrée illégale sur le
territoire et qu'on est à seulement une
soixantaine de kilomètres du foyer
épidémique
comment rien donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
il ya une réunion diplomatique qui est
prévue la semaine prochaine entre la
france et les comment on espère que
paris va hausser le ton et va
sanctionner les comores qui ne
collaborent pas malgré leurs engagements
internationaux remettre en cause le
confinement qui est décédé actuellement
ses frontières poreuses
la question de la santé publique c'est
pas de la pensée magique c'est pas juste
des déclarations quand vous avez
aujourd'hui dans un établissement
scolaire à cagnes des combats qui ont
duré des batailles avec des bandes de
jeunes qui ont duré toute la journée
vous rendez bien compte que l'ordre
public n'est pas assurée à mayotte
quand vous avez les déclarations du
préfet du ministre ou même du chef de
l'état qui sont usa mal par la réalité
qu'on constate sur le terrain d'arrivée
quotidienne de dizaines de kwassa-kwassa
qui rendent dans le lagon comme s'ils
étaient sur un lac est il sans contrôle
quand on entend que le centre de
rétention qui procède aux expulsions
relâche dans la nature des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui ont le coc
vide
on comprend que nous notre situation
sanitaire elle ne peut pas s'améliorer
tant qu'on n'a pas réglé le sujet du
contrôle des frontières rapidement
l'escalier sauf à la vaccination où en
est elle à mayotte
on imagine que ça pourrait être
difficile de d'acheminer le vaccin
notamment fighter biotech à cause des
modalités de conservation
oui parce que en fait il ya évidemment
la question qui reste posée qui entière
de savoir l'efficacité de ces vaccins
sur les variants
sud africain mais on a aussi deux
variants britannique à mayotte
donc ça ça reste quand même un vrai
point d'interrogation
on a entendu la directrice de la rs nous
dire que finalement files heures ce
n'était pas la meilleure option pour
mayotte et qu'il fallait attendre les
autres vaccins qui ne nécessitait pas
une chaîne du froid qui serait plus
difficile mais fondamentalement quand
vous avez seulement 900 doses de vaccins
qui sont livrés un mois après la
métropole pour commencer la campagne de
vaccins de vax de vaccination on voit
bien qu'il ya un vrai problème est qu'on
a des autorités qui ne prennent pas la
mesure de la gravité de la situation à
mayotte en attendent des mesures qui
sont pas des grandes déclarations mais
qui change la situation sur le terrain
merci beaucoup à vous estelle youssoufa
journaliste indépendante et président du
collectif des citoyens de mayotte et
l'inquiétude grandit on l'a entendu face
à l'évolution des nouveaux variants en
france et dans toute l'europe dans ce
contexte l'organisation mondiale de la
santé appelle également les pays
européens à accélérer leurs campagnes de
vaccination écouté le directeur de la
région europe pour le msx avons fait et
sanofi va augmenter la production de
pfizer et but ntech c'est ce dont nous
avons besoin plus d'entreprises qui
collaborent pour augmenter la capacité
de production
nous devons renforcer la production du
vaccin et nous avons nous besoin que les
gouvernements une communication très
clair car j'ai parfois l'impression que
les gens pensent que nous avons le
vaccin donc tout va bien
mais paradoxalement si vous pouvez vous
faire vacciner et que cela vous empêche
de tomber malade
vous pouvez tout de même continuer à
transmettre le virus la communication à
ce sujet est très compliqué
en syrie les conditions de vie
difficiles dans les camps des
d'humanitaire font craindre une flambée
des cas de coronavirus exemple la frime
dans le nord ouest du pays où les
hôpitaux se prépare on voit cela avec
grâce à ya un court moment d'insouciance
pour ses enfants du camp de moi ramadi
aa phryne pour eux pas de masque ni de
mesure de distance à sion sociale les
conditions de vie et de survie
constituent des urgences du moment
conditions d'hygiène promiscuité manque
de moyens la pandémie qui fait rage dans
le pays menace de se propager encore
plus rapidement dans ces camps aux
conditions sanitaires dramatique à
offrir le nombre total de 4 coronavirus
est de 1600 à l'hôpital astan esi on se
prépare à une flambée des cas ces
dernières semaines il ya eu beaucoup de
cas mais maintenant c'est beaucoup mieux
si la situation est particulière à
phryne dans le reste du pays c'est la
même chose
l'aide médicale peine régulièrement
arrivé mardi human rights watch a
souligné l'importance de la distribution
du vaccin dans le pays
les organismes qui comptent fournir à la
syrie des vaccins contre le coc u19
devrait s'assurer autant que possible
que ces vaccins puisse parvenir aux
personnes les plus vulnérables ou
qu'elle soit dans le pays fin janvier le
gouvernement syrien a approuvé son
adhésion au système kovacs mise en place
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
tout en soulignant que cela ne devrait
pas porter atteinte à la souveraineté du
pays
le pays déplore un peu plus de 14 mille
deux cents cas pour 930 décès depuis le
début de la pandémie
selon le ministère syrien de la santé
est plus dans l'actualité en tunisie sur
fond de manifestations contre les
restrictions sanitaires et ses
conséquences économiques
le gouvernement effectué son remaniement
ministériel tant attendus ont fait le
point sur place avec notre correspondant
abbas m shelly la tunisie en pleine
crise sanitaire économique mais surtout
politique avec un remaniement
ministériel
loin de calmer les tensions et de faire
l'unanimité dans la classe politique
tunisienne
un remaniement qui n'a fait que raviver
les tensions entre le premier ministre
mais chichis et le président
de la république le chef de l'état
continue de s'opposer à la nomination de
certains candidats
selon lui la constitution n'auraient pas
été respectées je suis prêt au dialogue
mais je ne suis pas prêt à parler avec
ceux qui ont volé le peuple tunisien je
ne reculerai pas devant mes principes
j'ai juré devant dieu en mettant ma main
sur le coran de respecter la
constitution
ce remaniement ministériel doit être
accompagnée d'une délibération en
conseil des ministres comme le stipule
la constitution une procédure qui n'a
pas été respectée selon le président de
la république qui refuse de recevoir ces
nouveaux ministres rendant des
portefeuilles clefs comme l'intérieur la
santé ou encore l'emploi toujours vacant
une impasse politique alors que le
gouvernement doit faire face à une vague
de manifestations de tout un peuple
exaspérés par la répression policière
les inégalités ou encore la corruption
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
en direct dans 30 minutes rester avec
nous sur rt france
[Musique]
nous sommes dans une évolution
concurrentiel permane dans laquelle
chacun essaie d'améliorer ses positions
tout en déstabilisant au delà des
démonstrations de force les guerre
frontale entre hyperpuissance deviennent
très incertain la guerre économique
évolue rapidement